il est là le plus haut qu'à cliquer sur
la vidéo bravant voilà c'est gratuit
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on va faire
demain faut prendre ces résolutions pour
2010 est doit prendre la résolution pour
2010 est d'être fort au dessin on va
voir ça a marché on sait d'avancé que
non ça fait trois ans qu'on s'exerce et
on stagne mais du progrès avant de
commencer à faire les oeuvres d'art qui
valent très cher j'aimerais souligner le
fait que je suis petit mon frère est
grand je suis très nul en musique mon
frère est fort en musique je suis très
nul en dessin mon frère est fort en
dessin lui fait des trucs comme ça comme
ça là il fait des gros hipster en short
comment il fait il fait comme ça la
danse est un peu moins regardé la
finesse du trait le talent du talentueux
florent aux chars et à côté son petit
frère fait de la musique comme ça
dessine comme ça l'air de rien la
rondelle vers la rondelle elle est là
elle est là et fait sa taille
[ __ ] c'est parti c'est bobby lapointe
vidéo je m'en bats les couilles vous
chercherez ce que c'est un manque de
respect total à bas avant la nouvelle
année on peut faire de la merde hein
dessine un calendrier
c'est simple c'est un rectangle c'est un
rectangle et dans le rectangle tu fais
ça et ensuite il ya des colonnes comme
ça hop
ok d'accord voilà il a trouvé c'est
parfait ça ressemblait à que des belles
choses abstraites leçon dessine une
boussole
ok c'est un rond avec dedans des
aiguilles qui font ça genre hockey et ça
se tourne m en valais la trouver il a
trouvé
pourtant on aurait pu croire que c'était
un oeil ou une bonne grosse chaîne non
non non dessine un ours en peluche
je vais faire base de ronds à temps je
tente une nouvelle technique c'est un
nouveau monde voici un nouveau mouvement
d'art c'est un peu comme le cubisme et
c'est donc ça c'est ses mains sa tête il
a vu du yoga le gall verra de fumer ça
non mais je sais pas je sais pas j'ai
pas chez party dit bien ok lowrie la
deuxième oreille le truc le machin
europe et dans quelques années dans une
feuille pourra faire un peu de cannabis
- as à me connaissait un ca autres
tourneurs de perm est tournée en france
et enfume un connard une feuille mec je
voyais je sais même pas dessiné une
feuille de cannabis jeu à sa montre bien
que moi c'est pas mon truc là la drogue
la gueu droh mec c'est un truc de ouf je
vois qu un ensemble et dès que le décide
et je fais de la merde c'est quoi cette
maladie mais voilà c'est ça que j'avais
en tête j'y arrivais pas le même temps
c'est incroyable ça petit quizz regret
c'est vraiment les 10 un cercle pour
meeke voilà elle a vu que j'étais d'une
petite bombe une piscine
ok vue de vue aérienne d'une piscine vue
aux drones dj ait oussa maintenant on
connaît bien les drones buzine csssae
dedans y'a des mecs comme ça mais tu es
le futur alors du coup c'est quoi qui la
bat teddy bear comment les gens dessine
dès l'hiver donc nous il s'est dit que
c'était peut-être une cacahuète ou une
poire ou un singe
non mais là j'avoue le frère version
était mieux quand même
non non non aller mais qui font des
petits ça va ça dessine bien ça a pris à
deux ans parce que gaza avait pas de
console à dessiner à sa lisez aussi des
romans et des mangas je suppose
tagro est le seul apte à domicile et il
a fait une souris au lieu d' accor yann
il avait un truc vaudou nommé au quai
non mais je vois gouverne il fait comme
mes profs quand j'étais au lycée et en
favorise certains noms mais c'est bien
tu reproduit bien le modèle social
pourri dans lequel on et bravo bon mec
on va mieux faire un scorpion très très
simple la queue avec le petit pic hockey
ensuite une fois qu'elle a que l'ail al
khor hockey ensuite la ja l'a7 et
ensuite la hyène rayée notre pain ils
voient la muraille de chine mais tu te
fous de ma gueule
ah c'est beau c'est un scorpion il a vu
la muraille de chine vont bien même
heure et de chine qui perd agressive
avec des queues et dépasse mon gars tu
peux acheter ton pain de la soucoupe
volante bohain mêlée nous mais bien le
dessin nul à chier à micro-ondes très
très simple ça tous les soirs tu mets un
pool est là dedans ojd chez micron wave
étage avait gelé bien fait mais
franchement rien rien la ressemblance
voilà le modèle sur lequel je me suis
basé ses seins elle j'ai regardé la
ressemblance [ __ ] c'est incroyable les
ingénieurs d'alger sont fiers de moi un
canon très très simple je suis allé
j'avais beaucoup cirque quand j'étais
petit je voyais la frappe canon qu'il
était là et un soutien avait déchu lcd
[Musique]
et google ne reconnaît pas un canon mais
mec c'est ça mais c'est un canot [ __ ]
mais qu'est ce tu veux que ce soit ça
mon gars c'est un cadeau beauté tôt mais
ta mère ta mère non mais c'est pareil
c'est cote alors le truc du cannabis je
sais à quoi ça ressemble j'arrive pas à
le faire mais que c'était j'ai mal
rédigé une telle maladie on va appeler
chercheurs smiley faye face à justin
visage smiley face nord faith tout court
face à poker fight du coup c'est une
feuille c'est une feuille c'est un mec
souris passée il failli ces âmes a eu
strawberry non non à un ours non aux
plats et lui la [ __ ] quarts des cas
c'est google qui l'a appris mon visage
pour un gâteau d'anniversaire pour du
pain et pour une fraise je reconnais ça
et tu connais pas mon truc
bixquert au québec mais mon bientôt lui
c'est un manga ces dessinateurs death
note km alors mon couteau il est très
bien pour moi en gagnant à jos a aussi
un petit mix entre la batte de baseball
et boomerang manga rigole rigole il y en
a qui comme et mac mais le gars quoi
celui qui design les skins de
counter-strike des couteaux accord donc
là t'as vu un couteau
d'accord moi je pensais à lui des petits
chèques ont été envoyées à google mais
ok ok suivant e s que si je prends un
modèle genre si je m'inspire pendant 8
secondes d'un écureuil au québec ça
m'énerve
j'ai envie de pleurer wes bush mexes
éviter pattes d'ef même loin il aimer
harry dans cette atroce
as tu envie tu attends clac clac clac
les mamelons les mamelons l'epita
culture libère un nuage vois ça je m'en
souviens ça y'a pas de soucis un nuage
ça ça passait bien à sa patte moi la
main pour les cas soc alors comment les
gens font des écureuils
explique moi j'avoue c'est mieux je peux
rien dire parce que dans tous les cas
cette ville ouais les mecs ce qui faut
il plus vieille que comme ça et on peut
pas parler faut que je prenne du recul
par rapport à ce que je fais là je trop
d'ego un toaster alors ça c'est comme
les micro ondes c'est tout pareil
ok vous faites ça l'homme est un tout
petit peu de perspectives et vous faites
une double tranche de grille-pain qui
ressort voilà samassa passe nickel vous
direz aussi une enceinte portatif mais
au choix moi je préfère la bouffe
siliana à travers la musique est beau ce
pas mr devait faire quoi gotti c'est
quoi gotti c'est le game of the year le
gars of the year hockey chl game of the
year c'est le goty game of the year
voilà c'est bon je fais games et game
over
le goty gfl d'otites bras elle aurait
beaucoup trop longtemps
vous l'avez constaté vous aussi allez
une petite dernière moi je veux le 6 sur
6 m en aller tranquillement un phare un
phare c'est quoi ça fait comme ça c'est
au bord de l'eau il ya la lumière comme
ça qui fait ça et voilà
m
alex wiens très je fais un trade du cdh
rivières le dentifrice [ __ ] mec c'est
incroyable fork fourchette fourchette
c'est quoi êtes vous actuellement c'est
juste un petit instrument comme ça avec
des pics qui permettent d'attraper la
nourriture de manière légale voir une
poule une poule une poule on l'a déjà
fait ces personnes ces vues aériennes
n'oubliez pas le drone dj ok on fait
exact dans la peur la piscine et c'est
une poule parfait et voilà six sur six
est tout pour moi l'année en beauté sur
du gros dessin de la bonne oeuvre d'art
vous avez senti la douille sétois
instructeur bigoudis tu a compté le
nombre de dessins je fais tu t'es aperçu
que j'en ai fait que sac à auprès
d'elodie effectivement il fallait que je
dessine un pot de peinture et il n'a pas
trouvé
il a pris ça pour une théière et
voilages enveloppes attitude n'était pas
allé mais ça vous a plu ben voilà on a
fini l'année sur du bon dessin bien beau
comme on les aime
1depuis savez il ya trois ans que vous
êtes fans de mes oeuvres d'art à jour
merci je sais très bien que si un jour
j'ai pu dessiner vous vous désabonner la
chaîne parce qu'elle n'aura plus
d'intérêt à vos yeux et je vous
comprendrez vous en faites pas mais
voilà aujourd'hui encore on l'approuvé 6
sur 6 ferme ta gueule inspecteurs
bigoudis à l'approché de personnes
regardent et portez vous bien tu as tout
le monde le pis
[Musique]